the jurgen experience a big
uh step forward a big improvement was
the hypnosis
the whole process of hypnosis is a sort
of a
deep relaxation at the same time you're
confronting this
these memories that helped a lot the
problem that people have with some
hypnosis sessions is that you can be led
into false memories
true and i think that does happen i
think
you know having been at many many uh ufo
gatherings i think
some people are mistaken about their
experience
um i believe and this is just my
personal opinion and understand i i
try to stick strictly to what i
experienced
and then my own musings my own
philosophy
i've had 45 years to develop i
i think that probably some people do
have
extremely unique uh dreams that seem so
real that uh
the actual physical event didn't happen
and i've
i've tried to argue with people about
how
um evil their intentions would be
you know and i'm saying uh you know the
decades that we've been si having these
sightings if that with that sort of
technology if they wanted to
replace us on this planet we'd never
know what hit us
no i i don't think that and actually i
think they're so advanced
that if there's sightings it's not an
accident
it's not like they slap their forehead
ah humans spotted me again i have to be
more careful next time you know
no i think they'd be perfectly capable
of being undetected we never have any
i think these little glimpses are
probably
a generalized a customization that we
might need as a species but
maybe on the other hand there's some
more
individual interest and i used to be
really skeptical i'd hear stories where
people
were describing them as having some
particular interest in them and i
think i tell them you know that'd be
like
them walking by an ant hill and saying
you know i think i'll have a
conversation with that little ant right
there
humans are a bunch of savages but at the
same time i i believe they probably do
have
if you saw one when you were eight years
old and you see one as an adult
they know it's you their ability to
process data and retain it and store it
is beyond anything we can imagine i
think
we're on the verge of that kind of a
paradigm shift
with uh something i would call the
computer brain interface the minute we
can do that kind of thing
uh it's uh kind of scary about the
possibilities but i've been at
conferences where people
talk about these uh beings as being
predatory or evil uh
one guy was trying to tell me that they
capture people
dissect them and dump their body and i
said oh
okay name one and he goes well so-and-so
and i go no no not the guy who puts this
theory out there
who's the victim who was found cut to
pieces
and then he i said so name one and he
gives me another name
it's still somebody who's promoting this
theory
and he just didn't get i said who's
what's the name of the victim and
he couldn't come up with one so i'm i'm
skeptical about that well anytime
there's
a fantastic subject whether it's ufos or
psychics or bigfoot or you you find
these people that just
want to believe you know and it's uh
very disheartening there's something
about that like it's hard to separate
truth from fantasy with a lot of these
folks and i think there's a lot of
fantasy and delusion going on
yeah and uh i have encountered other
people that i
do have uh do believe had legitimate
experiences and experiences but
i wouldn't consider them in the majority
and that's an unpopular view but uh
no i i share that view uh you know i'm
not completely skeptical but i'm
skeptical enough
i just i also know that it's in it
it's an aspect of human nature where
people want to
tell stories that make them unique
without actually having to have done
anything special in their life they want
to be special and some people
tell stories that make them out to be
very special because they've been chosen
to have this unique experience with an
extraterrestrial
you haven't they have and it it makes
them
it satisfies these delusions of grandeur
that some
yeah and i personally try to downplay
that aspect of it
i say i really favor the idea that this
was an
accident it was precipitated by my
foolish
move of getting too close i believe they
probably just took me aboard
in order to correct damage that they
were
a part of that
it was even unexpected for them so did
you have physical damage that you could
see
no but one thing that leads me to think
that
all of the repairs they might have done
weren't complete
was my initial uh
eeg brainwave scan and this was done
at the same hospital where muhammad ali
did his and
it was very what do you call
irregular what's the term
double blind dr kandel did not
tell the technician what i was in there
for
and so he wasn't looking for some
particular thing that would support or
deny
my experience so he just uh described
an unusual pattern uh
in the brain that in another
brainwave scan years later wasn't there
anymore
so uh what was this unusual pattern i'm
trying to think of the exact wording is
a
bi-synchronous wave alternating from
front to back
uh i remember those words
but i have uh the report
for both from both eegs so i've been uh
interested in finding
someone who might have uh been hit by
lightning or
uh you know some electrician that raised
up against the wire and
had a huge amount of energy come through
the brain
and and see if an eeg compares to this
weird pattern that they're describing
there but
uh there's a lot of speculation
opened and i of course have done trying
to figure out why what uh
happened there and there's uh some
amazing
uh things that uh
sometimes you know i try to stick to the
stuff i can document stuff that uh where
i have other witnesses
um and that you know
documentable that's that's what i go for
it i
i have this information concerning the
eeg
documents of it you know catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience